Well today I'm going to finish Tocqueville or to put it a different way,
I'm going to,
uh,
say what I can about Tocqueville on 50 minutes,
which is hardly finishing him.
And in fact,
we've hardly begun.
But I want to talk about two things to two aspects of the book today.
Again,
which,
well,
again,
only scratch the surface,
uh,
end up,
the,
those two topics are the following.
I want to talk about a little bit about the,
uh,
moral and psychological components or features of the democratic state,
which is largely the subject matter of volume two of the democracy.
And I also want to speak about the role of statesmanship.
Uh,
I mentioned earlier the issue of Tocqueville is educator as a kind of political
educator.
And I wanted to talk today,
uh,
end up today by talking a little bit about,
how he understands the role of the democratic statesman.
Uh,
but the first part,
first,
first subject,
uh,
is largely again,
the subject matter of volume to volume one of the democracy.
Uh,
as you've probably noticed,
focuses mainly not exclusively to be sure,
but mainly on watch.
I suppose we would call the social and political institutions,
uh,
of democratic society.
The institutional,
uh,
development,
of the democratic state,
uh,
volume to,
focuses on much more on,
uh,
so to call it the moral and psychological components,
of the democratic,
uh,
individual.
Uh,
Tocqueville here shows himself more concerned with the internal developments,
the,
again,
the moral and psychological determinants,
uh,
of the dem of democratic care of democratic character.
What is it to have a democratic soul,
uh,
so to speak,
that I think is Tocqueville's a concern in the second volume,
which in many ways,
at least to my way of reading it and makes volume to a sort of philosophically
richer,
uh,
discussion,
than volume one,
uh,
because precisely because it focuses on what has the democratic social state
done to us.
How has it transformed us,
uh,
as individuals?
How has it shaped us as individuals?
These were in many ways Tocqueville's deepest problems.
And in this part of the book,
he shows himself to be a kind of moral psychologist of the democratic soul.
Very much along the same lines as we saw in Plato for example,
in volume eight a of the republic where Plato speaks about the different kinds
of individuals,
the different kinds of souls,
uh,
that are appropriate and had been shaped by different kinds,
of,
of regimes.
What I'd like to start with,
I want to focus on three aspects.
Spend a little time on three of the components aspects,
uh,
psychological,
um,
uh,
components of the democratic individual and uh,
those in no particular order I want to discuss as compassion,
uh,
what this translation has as restiveness and self interest,
taken together.
I think these three terms are,
these three concepts constitute the,
as it were,
this sort of moral scope of the democratic state and describing these character
traits.
Uh,
Tocqueville is providing us with a kind of moral phenomenology and excuse a
pleaser rather pretentious term,
a kind of moral phenomenology of democratic life,
uh,
one in which we are invited to look and ask whether we see ourselves in this
description and whether we like,
uh,
what it is we see.
The first of these features that I want to focus on.
Uh,
the most important moral effect in some respects the democracy has had on its
citizen is for Tocqueville,
the constant tendency to make us gentler towards one another.
This is an old 18th century theme to make us more compassionate,
to make us a gentler in our manners,
habits,
morals with one another.
Uh,
this is an old problem,
modest skill.
Tocqueville's great.
Uh,
18th century precursor Montesquieu or had argued in the spirit of the laws.
Let's Redo that.
It was commerce that instituted a kind of,
of,
of softening affects,
uh,
on manners and morals,
moving us or taking us from a kind of warlike aristocratic ethic to one,
uh,
of gentler manners and morals.
And in Monte school had attributed this largely to the influence of,
of commerce roof.
So you will remember in the second discourse,
the discourse on inequality made PTA or compassion,
uh,
a repugnance to view the suffering of others,
is a fundamental feature of natural man.
Compassion for Russo remained a kind of remnant of our natural goodness,
uh,
the fact that we still can still cry or sympathize or empathize,
we might say with the plight of others.
Um,
even with the growth of noisier and more powerful passions,
this sort of capacity for sympathy or compassion remains even in civilized life,
a kind of remnant,
uh,
of our natural goodness.
But for Tocqueville,
this feature of compassion,
it's not so much a feature of natural man,
uh,
as it was for a Roussel,
but it is for democratic life,
democratic social life.
It is not nature,
but democracy that has rendered as gentler and led to this softening of morals
and manners.
What does Tocqueville may mean by that?
When he says life in democracy has become gentler in a very powerful chapter
called how mores become milder as conditions are equalized.
Here,
he describes some of the moral and psychological consequences,
uh,
of the transition from the age of aristocracy to one of democracy
under aristocratic times.
He says,
uh,
in Aristocratic Angel Ages,
individuals inhabited a world apart where members of one class or one tribe may
have been similar to one another,
but they regarded themselves as being fundamentally different from the members
of all other social classes or tribes.
Uh,
this did not so much render people cruel,
but it did render them indifferent to the pain and suffering of others outside
their group.
Under democracy,
however,
he says we're all are equal.
All of us tend to think in feel in nearly the same manner.
We no longer make or imagine these kinds of distinctions.
The moral imagination,
so called the democratic citizen,
is able to transport itself,
uh,
into the positions of others more easily than individuals living in an
aristocratic times all become a like,
or at least all our,
uh,
projected or perceived as being alike in our range of emotions,
sensibilities,
capacities for moral sympathies is people become more like one another.
Tocqueville says they showed themselves reciprocally compassionate regarding
their miseries and the laws of nations become milder.
The laws of nations become milder.
They showed themselves reciprocally compassionate to one another.
That transformation of one of the key ethics of social life for Tocqueville has
had profound effects on us.
It has certainly made people gentler and more civil to one another.
Such things he tells us as torture,
deliberate cruelty,
uh,
sort of spectacles of pain and humiliation that were once so much a part of
everyday life have largely been eliminated from the world.
I say largely not,
not entirely to be sure we more readily identify ourselves with the pain or
suffering of people possibly in,
in very different parts of the world world parts that we've never seen and may
never visit.
Consider for example,
our response to the victims of the tsunami in Indonesia or the genocide in
Darfur.
Uh,
all of these events effecting people in places,
again where we may never go nevertheless seem to have a claim on our moral
sympathies.
Uh,
President Bill Clinton,
uh,
profoundly captured this sense of enlarged moral sympathy when he told his
audiences,
I feel your pain.
I remember,
I don't know,
you probably won't remember that,
but you've probably heard the heard the expression.
It seems to show a kind of enlargement of the moral sympathies.
Being able to put oneself in the position,
uh,
of others,
who one doesn't know and may never meet.
Uh,
this is all a part of what Tocqueville understands.
This softening of morals under a democratic way of life.
And Tocqueville clearly regards this in many ways,
is a moral progress of sorts,
uh,
in our unwillingness to tolerate policies of deliberate cruelty.
And his statement,
uh,
perhaps,
premature,
uh,
that Americans of all the people in the world,
have succeeded or almost succeeded in abolishing the death penalty.
Not quite true.
Uh,
but nevertheless maybe more truer than than it is now.
in democratic centuries.
He says,
men,
uh,
but,
but all of this compassion here,
here's,
but here's the problem.
Here's the problem.
All of this compassion comes still at a price and democratic centuries.
He writes,
men rarely devote themselves to one another,
but they show a general compassion for all members of the human species.
They rarely,
he says,
devote themselves to one another.
This sort of generalized sympathy is genuine but soft.
Uh,
my ability to feel your pain does not really require me to do much about it.
compassion,
uh,
you might say,
turns out to be a rather easy virtue.
Uh,
it suggests sensitivity and openness.
it implies caring,
uh,
without being judgmental.
It is not entirely relativistic,
uh,
but it risks certainly refrains from imposing one's own moral judgments in way
of life upon others.
Does Tocqueville believe,
uh,
that democratic peoples or in dangers of becoming too soft,
to morally sensitive,
uh,
to incapable of exhibiting the kind of harsher,
what we might call more aristocratic virtues of nobility,
of self sacrifice,
of love of honor that formed the moral code of previous times?
Well,
the answer to that question is yes.
Uh,
he surely did believe that was becoming the case.
compassion is for Tocqueville in many ways,
an admirable sentiment.
And again,
it is one likely to expand our rage of moral sympathies,
but there is something called a kind of misplaced compassion,
uh,
that Tocqueville is very fearful about.
Compassion is a virtue,
but it carries with us with it like every virtue it's own particular forms of
misuse.
Uh,
for example,
when compassion becomes a standard by which to express our forms of moral
superiority to others,
I mean consider the following to be accused today,
particularly on places like college campuses,
to be accused of insensitivity to others,
to some kind of moral insensitivity is among many of us considered one of the
worst moral crimes imaginable.
Uh,
we must all care,
or at least we must all pretend as if we care.
Yes.
Or must be seen to care about the plight of others,
much worse off than ourselves.
And the result of this,
I think this is Tocqueville,
his point seems to be to create new moral hierarchies of compassion where one's
superiorities is a demonstrated by our heightened sensitivity and feeling for
others.
And it is precisely this kind of,
uh,
you know,
misplaced compassion.
You know,
asking the question,
who is the most sensitive,
uh,
among us a very Russo in type question.
This kind of,
uh,
misplaced compassion.
That is,
I think one of the psychological determinants of what we would call today a
political correctness.
Uh,
obviously a term Tocqueville does not use,
but you might think of the way in which the language of pity,
compassion,
sensitivity has so much shaped our moral vocabulary,
ways of thinking about ourself,
uh,
and judging others.
If you don't believe me,
watch almost any,
uh,
any daytime,
afternoon show like Oprah or any of these other shows,
you'll see exactly what I'm talking about.
Course you,
you fall,
you've all seen these shows
I think much,
many more times than I have.
But nevertheless,
compassion,
this is the first or one feature of democratic social life,
but it is not the only one.
It is conducted or at least it exists alongside another.
And at the core also of the psychological,
uh,
life of modern democratic citizens took the rights is a profound sense of
uneasiness,
of anxiety that Tocqueville caused by the French term Anchia Tude word that
maybe is difficult to translate into English on Kia to anxiety.
Uh,
in earlier translation,
this was called restlessness.
Uh,
in this particular translation,
you have restiveness,
uh,
to indicate the sort of perpetually dissatisfied character,
of the democratic soul.
I mean,
in many ways the democratic soul,
like democracy itself is never complete.
It is always a work in progress.
And this feeling of perpetual restlessness for Tocqueville is tied to the desire
for wellbeing.
And by that he means particularly material wellbeing.
It is the desire for happiness measured largely in terms of material happiness
that is the dominant drive of the democratic soul.
Uh,
in many ways,
Tocqueville brings to his analysis of democratic restiveness.
You can see in it something of the aristocrats disdain,
uh,
for the acquisition of you might see mere material goods for which most of us
have to work so hard to acquire.
I mean,
perhaps more than anything else.
This is what perplexes Tocqueville about democracy.
A democracy meant for him predominantly a kind of middle class,
a way of life,
bourgeois life made up of people who are constantly in pursuit of some obscure
object of their own desires.
I mean,
consider the following passage,
one of my favorite from the entire book,
uh,
from a chapter entitled why the Americans showed themselves so restive.
So restive in the midst of their wellbeing,
let me read it at some length in the United States.
He says,
a man carefully builds a dwelling in which to pass his declining years and sells
it.
Why the roof is being laid.
He plans a garden and he rents it out.
Justice,
he was going to taste it's fruits.
He clears a field and he leaves it to others to care for the harvesting.
He embraces a profession and quit.
He settles in a place from which he departs soon after,
so it was to take his changing desires elsewhere.
Should his private affairs give him some respite.
He immediately plunges into the whirlwind of politics and when towards the end
of a year filled with some leisure still remains to him.
He carries his rest of curiosity here and there within the vast limits of the
United States carrying his arrest of curiosity.
Wherever he may go,
he will just go 500 leads in a day in order to better to distract himself from
his happiness on the point of what a wonderful place to distract himself from
his happiness.
Death finally comes and it stops him before he is grown.
Weary of this useless pursuit of complete Felicity that always flees from him.
Does that passage sounded like anything we may have read here?
Does it not sound as if it is modeled almost exactly after Plato's description
of the democratic soul,
uh,
in book eight a of the Republic,
a person who is constantly moving,
constantly restless,
constantly unable to concentrate or to bear down on the one or very few things
that give life a sense of wholeness and meaning and integrity.
Here is the democratic,
uh,
man restive in the midst of wellbeing,
constantly moving ahead or moving to,
as he says,
distract himself from his own happiness.
Tocqueville writes here,
it seems with a kind of disdain for a life understood as a constant and in his
view,
self-defeating a pursuit of happiness.
The desire for wellbeing,
you might say,
becomes the right almost the right of the Democrat in the more one desires
happiness,
the more it eludes our grasp.
Uh,
so just after the sentence and the sentence just after the passage I just read,
Tocqueville says,
one is it first astonished to contemplate the singular agitation displayed by so
many happy men in the midst of their abundance.
And you can sense Tocqueville's irony in his use of the term.
So many happy the distractions,
the agitation,
uh,
complete agitation displayed.
He says,
by so many happy individuals in the midst of their abundance,
there's a world of social,
a condensed into those sentences.
His combination of words like agitation in abundance in the same,
again,
in the same context as the pursuit of happiness indicates for him that this way
of life is more likely to bring frustration and anxiety than it is to bring us
satisfaction,
uh,
and repose.
And he traces this continual restlessness,
uh,
back to what seems to be for the democratic social,
for the democratic individual,
the virtual obligation to be happy.
Uh,
I would ask you in this context if you have some time to read Darren Mcmahon's a
wonderful new book on a history of happiness,
uh,
to give you a little bit of an indication of the way this term has been used
throughout its history and the way in which in many ways the obligation to
pursue happiness,
uh,
to,
restiveness that kind of restiveness,
uh,
is the source of so much as he puts it singular,
the singular melancholy.
He says that the inhabitants of democratic lands often display a mid their
abundance,
life,
liberty,
the pursuit of happiness have become what one person wants called a kind of
joyless quest for joy.
And this is the second feature,
uh,
this restless or restive character of,
of,
of democracy.
And finally,
the third feature of democratic psychology that I want to focus on is this idea
of self interest or self interest.
Well understood,
uh,
as Tocqueville,
calls it,
this is a doctrine with which everybody is familiar from courses on moral
psychology,
on utilitarianism to modern courses and,
uh,
firm in economics and game theory and other things where the term self interest
is regarded almost just sort of a teller's manic pro has the almost talismanic
properties of explaining all kinds of human behavior.
But Tocqueville means something very specific by self interest or self interest.
Well understood.
It is in one sense,
the kind of,
you might say every day utilitarianism not in any strict sense of the term,
uh,
with which we are instinctively familiar.
When we hear talk,
we're,
when we hear are told things like honesty is the best policy and things like
this.
It seems simple and obvious enough,
but it in fact has a very complex and difficult,
uh,
history.
Uh,
by the time that Tocqueville wrote these chapters in the democracy,
theories of self-interest had long been a kind of staple,
uh,
of the European,
moral philosophy going back to the 17th century,
at least going back to people like Hobbs and,
and others.
Um,
the question is what,
what work does this idea,
this concept of self interest,
rightly understood,
understood,
do for Tocqueville and the first place he understands it somewhat differently
than I think we would when we hear the term self-interest.
Uh,
we are likely to think of it as soon as opposed to or to think of.
It's Antonym as indicating some kind of altruism,
a while intro while interest or self interest is thought of as inherently
self-regarding altruism or something like that.
It is in other regarded and other regarding disposition regarding the welfare
well wellbeing of others.
But when Tocqueville talks about self interest,
self interested behavior was put forward by him as a kind of comprehensive
antonym to behavior motivated by vanity,
by honor and above all by the concept of glory,
uh,
terms.
Remember thinking,
going back to Hobbs in some way and Hobbs is concerned to replace ideas of
vanity,
vainglory and pride with a notion of,
you know,
fear of death,
uh,
kind of self-interested,
behavior,
what glory a was for Tocqueville and,
and others,
uh,
a sense associated with war and warlike pursuits,
interest self interest was in variably associated with commerce and peaceful
competition.
In contrast,
in other words to the aristocratic,
uh,
concern with fame and honor,
interest was regarded.
Self-Interest was regarded as a relatively peaceful or harmless disposition
leading us to cooperate with one another for the sake of common ends.
The pursuit of self interest has a kind of unmistakably democratic,
uh,
and to Galitary an impulse behind it.
The pursuit of self interest is something literally everyone,
uh,
is able to follow even was such things is honor and glory seem to be,
by nature unequally,
uh,
available to different people.
And into this debate between,
uh,
between an ethic of honor and glory and an ethic of self interest or self
interest,
rightly understood.
Enters Tocqueville.
Enter is democracy in America.
He begins his chapter called how the Americans combat individualism by the
doctrine of self interest,
rightly understood with the following sentence,
with the following observation.
He writes,
when the world was led by a few wealthy and powerful individuals,
these like to farm for themselves,
they like to farm for themselves is sublime idea of the duties of man.
They were pleased to profess that it is a glue,
that it is glorious to forget oneself and that it is fitting to do good without
self interest like God himself.
This was the official doctrine of the time in matters of morality.
Speaking of Aristocratic Ages,
I doubt that man.
He says we're more virtuous in aristocratic centuries than others,
but it is certain that the beauties of virtue,
we're constantly spoken of only in secret.
He concludes,
did men study it's utility.
Um,
you might think about that passage perhaps,
uh,
in section,
but note that Tocqueville adds to the concept of self interest.
This idea or this modifier of well understood,
uh,
well understood.
What does this ad,
what does he intending that to say?
Uh,
self-interest.
Well understood is not the same thing as egoism or what Roussel called Mr pro
pro,
for example.
Uh,
it is not the desire simply to be talked about to be looked at,
to be first in the race of life.
Uh,
in that way rather self interest is connected or in self-interest.
Well understood is connected to this passion for wellbeing and the desire to
improve one's conditions that remain for Tocqueville.
A very important wellspring of human actions.
But it is important to remember that these are not the only desires are,
these are not the only motives for action.
Tocqueville probably is distinguished from many social scientists today by
suggesting that self-interest well understood is not some kind of universal
determinant,
uh,
of human behavior.
It is not,
it is not something a universal,
it is a product of a particular social state.
Uh,
a particular,
uh,
we might say the democratic social state.
He is not in this sense a kind of moral or psychological reductionist who wants
to see one cause of human behavior across all centuries and all climates.
Uh,
he is not saying that our,
uh,
behavior is self interested.
In fact,
in that very chapter on self interest,
rightly understood.
You will remember,
you may remember,
probably don't remember,
uh,
that he quotes in a footnote,
an essay by Montaine,
a name that I've mentioned before,
an essay by man chain called of Glory of glory to remind the reader that the
desire for fame and honor,
uh,
we'll always contend with the desire for wellbeing and happiness.
And in many ways these are,
uh,
two conflicting,
motives,
uh,
of,
of human behavior.
What did he believe that this ethic of self interest well understood would bring
about a,
again,
like compassion?
Uh,
the,
the doctrine of self interest has done much to sort of soften,
uh,
the,
the harsher features,
uh,
of the aristocratic ethics of,
of warlike,
of the warlike nobility,
uh,
self-interest well understood as a kind of antidote to,
an ethic of fame and glory.
And yet you can see throughout volume too,
especially how Tocqueville lament the decline of this older aristocratic codes
of honor and chivalry.
By contrast,
the doctrine of self interest,
well understood is not lofty.
He says,
but it is clear and sure it has characteristics of reliability and
predictability.
Uh,
it is not itself a virtue,
he says,
but it can form people who are,
and these are his terms,
regulated,
temperate,
moderate,
foresighted,
masters of themselves,
regulated,
temperate,
moderate,
force,
a farsighted.
Uh,
what does that sound like a think about,
think about that.
What kind of person is this and what has it created?
These are the virtues of the Democratic Republic.
Uh,
again,
these may not be heroic or extraordinary qualities,
but they have the,
they do have the virtue of being within the range of everyone.
But,
uh,
is such a,
it's such a code or a such a moral code,
a desirable for itself.
That's something that Tocqueville leaves a little bit up in the air of all
philosophical theories.
He calls them as he calls it,
the doctrine of self interest,
rightly understood is he says,
the most appropriate to the needs of men in our time.
Uh,
think about that judgment.
It is the most appropriate to the needs of men in our time.
It doesn't seem to suggest that this is a either universal or necessarily that
it is the best.
It is simply the best adapted to the needs of our time,
to our level of humanity,
to where,
where we are now.
And again,
there is,
there is an implicit to be sure and implicit kind of critique a suggested in
those,
in that phrase that you might think about as you read or as you go back to that
important chapter on self interest and its role in again,
the shaping of of the modern democratic individual.
So these three characteristics,
compassion,
um,
uh,
what was the other one?
What restlessness?
Yes.
Go good.
Yeah.
Can you can't even remember what I'm talking about.
Restlessness and self-interest.
I was just,
I was quizzing him.
I was check,
checking,
just checking.
Okay.
It's not,
it doesn't have anything to do with short term memory loss.
Hm.
These are,
these are what is what has shaped us.
And,
uh,
Tocqueville holds this ESOP as a kind of portrait,
hey,
democratic individual,
uh,
and also of course primarily to not so much to the democratic individual,
but to his readers back in France,
uh,
and saying this seems to be the future shape of,
of humanity,
of democratic humanity.
Uh,
we need both to adapt to it.
In some ways.
We have to recognize that this is what's coming and adapt to it,
but we also have to be,
to some degree,
wary of what of what is coming and what kind of people we may create out of
ourselves,
what may be created.
And this brings me to the,
to the theme that I mentioned at the beginning about democratic state craft
democratic education.
What is the role,
uh,
of the statesmen,
in a democratic age?
How should one adapt as well as try to guide these features?
A democracy in America,
uh,
is a work
of political education,
a supreme work of political education addressed to leaders or potential leaders,
uh,
not only for Tocqueville's time,
but for the future.
The possibilities of statecraft are as they are always dependent on what we
understand politics and political science to be.
What is it in the introduction to the book in one of those characteristically
epigrammatic sentences,
and you should be,
uh,
attuned.
Today's Tocqueville often likes to give these one sentence paragraphs to
highlight an idea,
you know,
to really make it stand out.
I don't recommend it for you,
uh,
but for him,
he takes one sentence and can make it,
turns it into a paragraph.
He talks about this book,
he says,
is a new political science for a world all together.
Knew that that statement has to jump out at you.
What the page,
what is this new political science,
a new political science.
Again,
in some ways following Machiavelli who had,
uh,
that departs from the ancients.
Uh,
but perhaps also from his modern predecessors too,
like Machiavelli and Hobbes or Locke and Rousseau.
What is the distinguishing feature of the political science,
uh,
for a new democratic age for a world altogether new
Tocqueville's new political science,
let me suggest to you,
is based on a novel and profound understanding of the relationship between
history or historical forces and human agency between individual power and
individual powers or agency and historical forces.
Let me try to explain what I mean by that.
Is any reader of the democracy quickly notes even from the opening pages of the
book,
Tocqueville attributes a kind of providential power,
uh,
to history,
the immense,
a centuries long progress,
uh,
or transition from the aristocratic to the democratic era seems to be as he
describes it,
almost an act of divine providence,
almost of divine will.
He warns his readers,
uh,
that it is a mistake.
Uh,
it is self defeating to try to re to resist or to turn back,
uh,
this movement.
This would be futile.
It would not only be futile.
He even suggests it would be impervious.
It would be in some ways to go against the will of God as if the hand of God,
we're behind this immense historical progress or process.
Tocqueville,
no doubt deliberately overstates that argument,
but he does.
So I think in order to make a serious and profound point,
our politics are politics are deeply embedded within long structures of human
history that we can do little to alter and escape.
We seem to be deeply embedded.
We as individuals deeply embedded within these structures.
This is it to two or to use a term that modern political scientists often use to
describe this.
It is an argument from what is often called path dependency.
That we are again,
deeply embedded within historical processes,
tendencies,
uh,
paths of development that we can do little to resist or control.
And in many ways,
Tocqueville,
often you will find Tocqueville.
Often writing is if he has some kind of historical or sociological determinist
allowing little room for individual initiative or agency words like fate,
destiny,
a tendency a are frequently used throughout the book,
uh,
to underscore the limits of political action.
I would even be an interesting experiment,
uh,
or,
to go through the book page by page and find how many of those,
those kinds of words,
tendency,
fate,
destiny,
these kind of deterministic words that,
that suggest irresistible movements,
movement,
uh,
of history.
Uh,
he,
how many times he uses this and these Indian what contact contexts and he
frequently offers predictions throughout the book on the basis of what he
regards to be underlying historical and social trends.
You can hardly read a page of the book,
sometimes not even a paragraph without finding in it some kind of prediction,
uh,
based on,
these trends.
I again,
I would ask you,
you know,
if you have time,
go through the book,
you don't have time this semester.
Maybe it will be a great senior essay later on to go through the book and find
examples.
As many as you can have.
Again,
predictions that Tocqueville makes on the basis of these historical,
uh,
these,
this claim about historical forces,
uh,
in much of this seems to deny taken literally much of this would seem to deny
the role of independent,
uh,
human initiative.
Uh,
or statecraft in history.
Consider the following passage from pages one 54 and 55 of your translation.
Here's what Tocqueville writes about,
the Statesman.
He says sometimes after a thousand efforts,
the legislators succeeds in exerting an indirect influence and the destiny of
nations and then one celebrates his genius,
whereas often the geographical position of the country about what she can do.
Nothing.
A social state that was created without his concurrence,
mores and ideas of whose origin he is.
Ignorant,
a point of departure,
unknown to him,
impart irresistible movements to society against what she struggles in vain in
which carry him along.
In turn there.
There you go.
He gives us a list of all of the different determinants of,
of,
of human,
you know,
surrounding conditions,
a geography,
morays,
social position.
These,
he says,
impart an irresistible movements to society.
There is that kind of deterministic language again against which he,
the statesman can do nothing and yet he begins this.
He begins that little statement by saying that after a thousand efforts he
succeeds in exerting an indirect influence and the destiny of nations.
And then he is celebrated as a great genius.
You can see Tocqueville's irony and what appears to be downplaying,
uh,
the,
abilities or the role of the legislator,
the Statesman to,
to effect a change with any significant kind.
Uh,
I don't like to be political,
but one might wonder what our president would have made of that,
uh,
head he read that passage or thought about it or those around him had thought
about it a couple of years ago before our current,
uh,
miseries,
began.
Uh,
anyway,
this passage,
uh,
almost seems to be mocking the claims of Machiavelli or Rousseau who,
who saw the ability of the new of a new prints or a legislator to found people's
institutions.
Uh,
Tocqueville seems to regard that the legislator can do relatively little on his
own,
but as strongly hemmed in by a host of factors,
geography,
social customs,
morality,
again,
over which one can do little,
the legislator is more like a ship's captain,
uh,
dependent on the external circumstances that control the fate of the ship.
And he even goes on to say,
the legislator resembles a man who plots his course.
In the middle of the ocean.
Thus he can direct the vessel that carries him,
but he cannot change its structure,
create wins or prevent the ocean from rising under his feet.
Uh,
all of this seems to be on this side of those historical features that,
that limit what we can do.
Yet if Tocqueville,
uh,
often writes as if the statesmen is hemmed in by these kinds of circumstances,
he also,
and you see this especially throughout volume too strongly opposes our systems,
all intellectual or philosophical systems of historical determinism that deny to
us the power of human agency.
A while he's sometimes writes to shame or to humble,
uh,
the pretension of human greatness.
He is just as concerned about the tendency,
in fact,
the very dangerous tendency towards self abnegation that denies,
uh,
the denies the role of the individual in politics and history.
He often writes as if the,
it is the peculiarity of democratic times,
uh,
when our peoples are considered equal in therefore all of us considered equally
powerless to effect or change anything.
And again,
I would ask who has not felt this way at some time?
Maybe all the time that with all of us being again,
more or less equal,
no one seems to have the power kind of singular power to effect any great social
change.
There is one wonderful chapter,
uh,
among others,
but I'll just mention one look at the chapter.
Uh,
and I can't recall off hand the exact,
uh,
number of the chapter,
but the one called on historians on the role of historians in democratic and
aristocratic times and how we,
how we shows us that in aristocratic ages he's thinking particularly of the
ancient world,
historians attributed to extraordinary individuals,
all the power to affect nations and change nations.
But in democratic times,
in modern times,
we tend to think of historians.
What one might also take as term historian to include social science as well.
Uh,
we tend to project systems which deny the power,
uh,
the unique power of the individual.
We are all a product of,
of,
of vast,
uh,
you might say historical or causal circumstances over which the individual has
no control.
Think of the way in which a Marxism,
uh,
again,
denies the power of the individual Friday and analysis.
Did Not,
you know,
sees all of our desires and motives as determined by forces over which we have a
little control.
All kinds of economic theories of development,
again,
which a cs all,
uh,
acting under a certain kind of uniform rules of human behavior.
Where is the,
where is the room for the individual?
It's that,
that chapter is a wonderful illustration of Tocqueville's general point.
So what is then his teaching?
Uh,
and more specifically,
what is his vibe?
Is his advice,
uh,
for the state craft,
of the future?
Uh,
and it seems that the,
by the end of the book,
Tocqueville is walking on a very narrow tightrope.
He wishes to convince his contemporaries,
uh,
that the democratic age is upon us.
That the transition from aristocracy to democracy is irreversible.
That it cannot be a dead,
it cannot be resisted.
And what he calls the Democratic Revolution,
uh,
is an accomplished fact.
And yet at the same time,
he wants to instruct us that what form democracy will take in the future will
very much depend on will on intelligence,
on what he's sometimes called enlightenment.
And especially on an individual human agency.
What form democracy will take.
Democracy may be inevitable.
Equality.
The age of equality may be inevitable,
but democracy is not of all one piece.
It depends not just an impersonal historical forces but on what you might call
the act of virtue and intelligence of individuals ranging from self interest,
rightly understood to honor and ambition.
Democracy can still take many forms and whether it will favor liberty or be
favorable to liberty or does some kind of collectivism is for him very much an
open question.
What form democracy will take and Tocqueville returns to this theme.
It's very,
very important theme.
In the last very last paragraph of his book,
I am not unaware.
He tells his readers that several of my contemporaries have thought that peoples
are never masters of themselves.
Here below there's little we can do.
We are never met and that they necessarily obey.
I do not know which insurmountable and unintelligent force born of previous
events,
the race,
the soil or the climate.
Those he says are false and cowardly doctrines that can never produce anything
but weak men and pusillanimous nations.
That is to say these doctrines of historical determinism have an actual effect
on people.
It makes us weak.
It makes us cowardly.
It makes us,
uh,
it makes entire societies and it enervates entire society.
And yet he continues.
Providence has not created the entire race entirely independent or perfectly
enslaved.
It traces.
It is true.
He's speaking about providence.
It traces,
it is true a fatal circle around each man that he cannot leave.
But within this vast limits man is powerful and free.
So too,
he says with people,
Tocqueville leaves us,
in other words,
not with the solution,
uh,
but rather with a paradox or I would say a challenge for us to consider.
We are determined but not altogether.
So the statesmen must know how to navigate the shoals between historical,
social and cultural forces over which we have no say.
And those matters of institutional design and moral suasion that are still
within our power to affect pip.
Politics is intelligent.
People have always known,
uh,
which is not to say all people to be sure,
but as intelligent people have known,
uh,
is a medium that takes place within language.
It is a matter of providing people with the linguistic and the rhetorical
abilities,
both to construct their pasts and to imagine their futures.
It is language,
uh,
going back to Aristotle,
it is logo.
So there's language that gives us a latitude and ability to adapt to changing
circumstances and to create new ones.
Tocqueville provides us living in a democratic age with the language to shape
the future of democratic societies.
What we do with that language,
how we apply it to new circumstances and conditions that Tocqueville could never
have imagined will be,
of course,
entirely up to us.
Uh,
and on that note,
I have to end Tocqueville.
And Wednesday I'll see you for our last class and I'm going to talk about where
we go from there.